la pandémie a provoqué une grande prise
de conscience collective on a
soudainement compris l'importance de
l'autonomie alimentaire et dans un
secteur bien précis de l'agriculture
cette prise de conscience a provoqué
depuis le printemps 2020 un phénomène
inattendu dessert autrefois entièrement
destinés à la production de fleurs font
désormais une place aux fruits et aux
légumes
une façon de maximiser l'utilisation des
infrastructures mais qui comporte son
lot de défis
[Musique]
au jeu
au jardin andré carbonneau on cultive
des fleurs de père en fils depuis cinq
ans pas sur une superficie de 2700
mètres carrés ont produit des plants de
fleurs et des pousses de légumes à
repiquer destiné surtout aux jardins
domestique
avant le mois de juillet on aura écoulé
presque tout l'inventaire
particulièrement je vous dirais que le
maximum quatre semaines c'est fait la
pandémie a eu son effet
l'horticulture a monté en flèche
mais pour andré carbonneau la pandémie
aura aussi été l'occasion de concrétiser
une idée qui lui trottait dans la tête
l'idée du venu à un moment où ce que on
était fermé le gouvernement avait fermé
les jardineries nous allons n'étaient
pas déclarés essentiels on qu'on pouvait
pas vendre nos produits
et puis on se disait dans le désert on
est au mois de mars est encore temps
pour nous de tous tu es sûr de repartir
puis de tourner sans légumes pour
nourrir nos enfants cet été
le producteur de louiseville lance alors
l'idée de transformer sa production de
fleurs en production maraîchère en
espérant que le gouvernement entendre
son appel on est en mal à lire c'est
vous qui l'avez dit un moment le choeur
des choses le plus important c'est le
carburant c'est la bouffe pour les gens
quelques jours plus tard il ouvrait ses
portes en intégrant peu à peu sur ses
étalages une production maraîchère
un peu comme vous voyez dans la soirée
ici à à mesure que les plans se vendent
comme on va sortir des flammes ont
rempli avec du matériel qu'on va
produire maraîchers
voyez où nous la baille à des aubergines
et qu'on enlève les cas on va continuer
à transplanter aubergines en s'emmenant
ici remplir la salle pour une deuxième
utilisation à l'installation au delà de
toute façon alors si je capable dé série
jusqu'au mois d'octobre mais ça me
permet de garder mon monde plus nombreux
le fait d'avoir pandémique eu un
engouement pour les produits du québec
m'a dit oui c'est peut-être sol la voix
c'est pour ça que marche et il n'y a pas
de limite et hervé barjols cultive lui
aussi des plantes ornementales
il représente les producteurs en serre
du québec comme d'autres il souhaite
profiter de la demande actuelle mais
espère aussi rentabiliser ces
installations qui ne servent que
quelques mois par année pour produire
ces vivaces et c'est annuel savoure très
très chargée sur le front ouest or pin
pour l'utiliser pendant que six mois
dans l'année ou quatre mois c'est
ridicule
parce que ce qu'on est bon se faire
pousser des fleurs et des plants à
repiquer et faire pousser des points
c'est sûr on lâchera pas ça c'est là
qu'on est bon mais son pouvez compléter
un peu la saison que ce soit
financièrement ou juste pour rouler les
équipements mais ça se pense que c'est
une voie d'avenir
mais hervé barjols et andré carbonneau
sont bien conscients le passage de la
production horticole à la production
maraîchère ne se fera pas sans
difficultés
on a suivi le coup comment faire pousser
des légumes et on s'est rendu compte
qu'ils ont
laissé la nuit là jour nuit et jour
c'est l'eau et l'huile quand j'ai lancé
l'idée j'avais aucune idée de l'ampleur
de ce que ça représentait le maire ces
deux mondes différents c'est
complètement deux mondes différents je
crois que c'est même assez difficile d'y
arriver parce qu'on n'a pas de volume
mais je me dis qu'on est capable
d'apporter une forte dans le marché
un marché où les relations d'affaires
sont déjà bien établis avec les grands
producteurs maraîchers
alors on va faire plus tôt tout ce qui
est dans les légumes feuilles que soient
les seuls à des radios lesquels ça c'est
plus facile à faire mais c'est à
l'automne que vont embarquer camp que
les productions maraîchères du québec
commencent à diminuer à cause de la
tempête il faut faire des produits que
ces grands producteurs l'eau ne font pas
ou très peu faut aller dans les produits
de niche alors nous on va se concentrer
sur les circuits courts j'ai déjà des
contacts avec des gens qui font des
fleurs comestibles il ya des petits
maraîchers de famille il ya aussi des
gens qui font des paniers évidemment
qu'un qui sont rendus à l'automne dans
leur panier il ya moins de produits
frais c'est plus des légumes racines
ainsi de suite si moi avec mes serbe les
musiques marre je peux le revendre pour
dire vrai agrémenter vos paniers avec un
peu de salade un peu de berger pour que
eux aussi allongent leur saison jusqu'à
maintenant au québec environ une
trentaine de producteurs de plantes
ornementales au décidé d'ajouter une
saison de culture maraîchère mais est-ce
rentable
le jeu en vaut-il la chandelle
by la première année c'était infernal
les légumes ont plutôt été de données
qui ont été vendues l'an de vendue pour
quelques centaines de dollars mais
c'était c'était vraiment plus donner
parce que je n'avais pas de marché alors
cette année ce que j'ai fait j'ai passé
je fais l inverse j'ai été voir les
besoins l'aubergine africaine le piment
enfants à voir que j'ai j'ai ciblé que
j'ai un client qui devrait acheter toute
la récolte donc et a impliqué très con
là
les subventions et rabais de tarifs
d'électricité
accordé récemment aux entreprises
serricole ont contribué à convaincre
certains producteurs de fleurs plus
réticents à faire la transition vers le
maraîcher dernièrement j'ai parlé à des
gens du mapaq sont débordés de demandes
j'espère que ces programmes l'eau vont
assécher le nez sur quelques années
parce que les gens ont tendance à
paniquer dit je veux le faire tout de
suite même le ministère encourage
nommément les gens à convertir puis à
faire des légumes de l'otan
dans le moment il n'y a pas de plafond
on est très loin de satisfaire le québec
le québec est encore très tributaires de
l'importation du mexique des etats-unis
de partout gamme n'empêche les
producteurs de fleurs qui ont entrepris
en 2019 le virage maraîchers dit être
encore en expérimentation
leurs groupements continue de leur
offrir des formations et négocie avec
des associations de détaillants pour
leur faciliter l'accès au marché
on fera pas concurrence aux prospère de
marée chez auchan ou enserre
l'inquiétait voice et ils ont pas qu'ils
ont pas de crainte à avoir
si on amène 10% à 15% de plus de
produits locaux aux marchés ça va nous
et le flou depuis
j'ai bon espoir qu'à la fin ça va être
rentable je vise pas à être riche si ça
fait juste payer ces frais peuvent pas
travailler mon nom ça soit déjà
magnifique
[Musique]